[Music]
i watched jeopardy last week and i hate
to say this
but i think maybe alex trebek has been
hosting that show
too long
i really think so i was watching the
show and i was watching the show and i
think i think alex trebek is starting to
lose it i really do i think he's going
off the rails a bit take a look at this
episode
five vowels for 800. channing tatum
takes vodka cranberry juice 400 gallons
of blood and a lime wedge
add this fart fruit juice to make it a
sea breeze
what was the u.s mail
men at work for 1600 steve carell is a
modern dane hitler romantically linked
to this kitty tractor pull lovely my
dear yet oh so deadly
[Music]
the old curiosity shop five dollars for
600.
hey mister it's a small circular breed
of dog that stores bile in a roman
catholic church
the rotating part is the cylinder
behind bars for 400.
this alcoholic beverage is made from the
bloodiest hanukkah oil but you had to
spit with the wind atop a frozen wonder
girl
his name was dwight david eisenhower
[Applause]